everyone welcome back and let's write
some more neat code today so today let's
solve the problem valid anagram and
we're actually going to be solving this
a few different ways so maybe you will
learn something today so we're given two
strings s and t and we want to return
true if
t is an anagram of s or basically if
both of the strings are anagrams of each
other and false if they're not anagrams
so main thing that they don't mention in
this problem is what exactly is an
anagram and basically it means that you
know to call t an anagram of s is
basically saying that using the
characters of s all of the characters
right every single character we can
create the string t so basically they're
made up of the exact same list of
characters so
so the string s you can see that it has
three a characters one n character a one
g character one r character and one m
character so it's made up of in total
seven characters so that must mean that
if t is an anagram of s
t has to have exactly seven characters
as well which clearly it does have seven
characters but are they the exact same
characters as i wrote up above well
let's check okay does it have three a
characters one two three yep it has
three a characters does it have a single
n character yep it has exactly one n
character does it have a g character yes
exactly one g character uh does it have
an r exactly one r it has exactly one m
as well so it has
uh the exact same characters and the
same quantity of each character that's
also important right because three a's
have to exist in t as well so in this
case they're anagrams we can return true
that's great uh second example uh rat
and car
both of them have an r both of them have
an a character but one of them has a t
while the other has a c character
they're both the same length they're
both length three but they have one
differing character so they're not
anagrams we return false in this case so
the first solution i wanted to talk
about is probably the most obvious one
and probably uh by just listening to me
talk about anagrams you might be able to
come up with this by yourself we just
want to count the occurrences of each
character in both
both strings right
what's the easiest way to do that well
you could use an array or a hash map
that's what i'm going to use i like hash
maps basically what the hash map is
going to look like so basically we're
going to have two hash maps one for each
string and the key value in the hash map
is going to be the character so for
example a in string s right let's use a
different color so a in string s so how
many a's are there there's three a's
right the the value is going to be the
count the key is just going to be the
character we're going to do that for
every single character in the string so
that's a n has one g has one r has one
and m also has one and we know that t is
the exact same right as three a's one n
etcetera etcetera right i could continue
this so in the end you can see that
they're the exact same hash map right
once we've built these hash maps we can
then go through the keys and then
compare that the counts for each
character are the exact same which in
this case yes it is so then after that
comparison then we know that they're
anagrams then we can return true and how
exactly i'm going to do that is i'm just
going to actually iterate through the
keys of one of these so in this case for
example i'm just going to iterate
through all the keys in string s so a n
g and then make sure the counts right we
want to make sure that the count of each
of the characters is the exact same and
if we make sure that both strings have
the exact same length before we actually
do the hash map stuff then we actually
only have to iterate through one of the
hash maps and comparing it to the other
hash map right because if we make sure
that
t has exactly three a's t has exactly
one n t has exactly one g etcetera
etcetera if we make sure that all of
that is true and that's inside of t then
we pretty much know t is exactly the
same as s because they have to be if
they are the same length so that's the
solution uh time complexity of this is
big o of n uh or rather let's say big o
of s plus t
uh because we're gonna have to iterate
through both of the strings so we uh so
that's the time complexity the memory
complexity is the same s plus t because
clearly we are building hash maps that
are gonna be of size
potentially up to the size of s and the
size of t so the downside of this
solution is we are going to need some
extra memory and the second solution
that i show you is actually going to
solve that memory problem so stay tuned
in the video if you want to see that but
for now let's jump into the coding
solution of
this hashmap solution that i'm talking
about okay so now let's code it up and
like i mentioned a main thing we're just
going to be doing is counting the
characters in both of the strings so
we're going to create hashmaps for that
this is how you can do that in python
but remember before we even do that we
want to make sure that the length of
both strings is exactly the same because
if they're not the same length then of
course it's impossible for them to be
palindromes so we can immediately whoops
then we can immediately return false if
they are not the same length otherwise
we can actually run the algorithm so
let's just
uh go through the strings at the same
time so we can iterate uh basically
through the length of the string s
because we know they're both the same
length so we can just use the index i
for both of the strings uh count s is
basically going to count the occurrence
of each character in uh string s of
course so each time we see the a
character so a character is basically
going to be s at index i that's the key
of the hashmap uh every time we see a
character we want to increment the count
of that character by one so can we just
say one plus this can we just say one
plus this well in python no because what
if that character doesn't even exist in
the hashmap yet then this is gonna throw
a key error right key does not exist so
to get around that in python at least
there's a nice little function uh with
hash maps that you can use that's called
get so
get this uh you know this key and it'll
basically do exactly what's being done
over here on the left side but the
second parameter to this function is
basically a default value so 0 is the
default value in this case that means
that if this key does not exist in the
hashmap then the default value that this
function is going to return is 0 which
is of course what we would want it to
return right so with this line we're
just counting the occurrences of each
character in string s we can do the
exact same thing uh with string t just
by copy pasting this and then changing
everything to t so making sure we use
the t hash map and making sure we
iterate through the string t right t at
index i so that's pretty much it for
building the hash maps next we want to
iterate through the hash maps and make
sure the counts are the same so let's
say for c for the character in count uh
s so we just want to make sure the
counts of both uh hash maps are the same
so count that character i is equal to
count t
at character i so the counts are the
same actually in this case we'd want to
make sure that the counts are not the
same because if they're not the same
then we basically know to return false
immediately because
then we know that they're not anagrams
if you have noticed we're iterating
through the keys in python at least
we're iterating through all the key
values of account s right the the count
map of string s and c
is going to be the key but what if that
key does not exist in the t map right
count t what if it doesn't exist in this
map well again we can use that default
function of get so that it doesn't throw
a key error for us and it'll return a
default value of zero so
that's uh basically the entire algorithm
right we built the hash map we performed
the check and then if if we never return
false here that must mean that they are
anagram so then if the loop exits we can
go ahead and return true that's the
entire code let's run it to make sure
that it works so you can see on the left
it does run it's relatively efficient
though it doesn't reflect that on leak
code but basically you can actually do
exactly what i just showed you with one
line of code at least in python but i i
think this is kind of cheating and it
probably won't work in an interview but
counter is a data structure in python
which is a hashmap but it basically
counts things automatically for you so
we can run a counter on s and we can run
a counter on t and if these counters are
exactly equal basically by doing the
equal sign i'm just doing what i did
down here right with the for loop but
the equal sign does it for us instantly
so
uh it does that and then we can just
return the result if they're equal it'll
return true if they're not equal it'll
return false i can run that and make
sure that it works which it does and
it's actually slightly more efficient i
guess the overall time complexity and
space complexity of both of these
solutions is exactly the same just this
takes more lines of code because we're
actually explicitly writing out all the
operations so now what if as a follow-up
question your interviewer asks you how
can you make a solution where we don't
actually need extra memory can you do a
solution with of one memory how would
you solve that problem it's a good
question and the solution is actually
simpler than you might think
just kind of thinking about how anagrams
work if you took all these characters
and put them in a hash map where we can
count the occurrences then it's pretty
easy to check if they're equal but isn't
there another way what if we
made sure that the characters show up in
the exact same order every single time
what do we mean by order well one
possible way would be sorted order right
because if they're if they really are
the exact same characters then if we put
them in sorted order then they should
actually become the exact same string
then we can literally just do an equals
operation on both of the sorted strings
and guarantee that they're going to be
equal but the downside is what's the
time complexity of doing sort well in
some cases with bad sorting algorithms
like bubble sort or something it might
be n squared right
good sorting algorithms can do it in n
log n time right worst case big o of n
log n time uh but you know the space
complexity is kind of iffy usually
sorting algorithms at least good ones
actually do use extra memory they use of
n extra memory but sometimes they don't
sometimes they can be really optimized
and actually run on
constant memory constant extra memory it
will depend on which built-in library
function you're using but usually for
some reason interviewers just assume
that sorting doesn't take extra space so
it's definitely something to discuss
with your interviewer yeah so basically
if you just sort it it solves the
problem for you right because if we took
anagram and we sorted it we'd get aaa g
m n r right it would be the same order
and then if we take the this string t
sort it it's the exact same characters
so when we sort it it should be the
exact same string and it is so now let's
get into the code of this solution okay
so now you can see that these were the
two solutions we originally came up with
now let's do the third and final
solution
we can just run the sort function on s
and the sort function
the built-in sort functions at least in
python on t as well and if they're
exactly equal it'll return true if
they're not equal it will return false
let's run it to make sure that it works
and on the left you can see yes it does
it's relatively efficient but
technically it's not as efficient as the
two previous solutions that we came up
with below and who knows maybe your
interviewer will actually want you to
write out your own sorting function for
this but i really hope that this was
helpful if it was please like and
subscribe it supports the channel a lot
consider checking out my patreon where
you can further support the channel and
hopefully i'll see you pretty soon
thanks for watching